hey travis
the first episode of nitro circus was
that when your dad jumped off the boat
am i right on that so yeah we went down
to panama i wasn't the first episode but
um
yeah he so my dad always wore like just
cut off jeans and he went down there in
dc
hooks him up with these uh you know
these big old board shorts and he's
stoked and
plus he's a lot older now he jumped out
of the boat so we're driving
and he's yelling at us hey come on you
you [ __ ] basically jump out jump we're
like dad we're going 90 we're not
jumping out of the boat
he's like ah [ __ ] jumps out the boat
well he lands in one he's old too
we're going 90. yeah and all the pieces
of junk boats that we have back home we
had like
you know checkmates and stuff maybe like
65 70. that
20 mile an hour hits so he goes in and
it rips his so he does the splits when
he lands please
he can't do the splits and um he
shatters his pelvis
starts bleeding out now he's my dad's
drill sergeant the marine corps he
doesn't
doesn't you know ever let anyone see him
in pain
so he swims back to the boat and he gets
on he
pulls himself up broken pelvis bleeding
out we didn't know it
and he just kind of sits on the back for
a while and i said dad are you okay
he said nope no one's dying
is everyone's kind of laughing and uh
like hey you wanna you want a pain shot
or you know because one of the doctors
is on just saw and i'm kind of seeing
them kind of go white
and uh dad goes yep i looked over i'm
like
holy [ __ ] he is dying like i've never
seen him take so much like he'll take
advil but he doesn't believe in
pain meds he doesn't believe in like
anything and i'm like man he just took a
shot and he'd never
if he ever asked me if he's hurt he says
no i'm like i really think he's dying i
said hey
dad you want to go back uh back on shore
he's like i need to go to the hospital
you know
whenever you guys have done this um
so they're kind of going around i'm like
you know hey guys let's let's head back
you know
it's pretty rough out in panamaki now we
head back by this point he's pretty
white
and but he's still you know so he gets
up he walks not well mind you
but he he walks you know doesn't make
too much of a face broken pelvis
bleeding out
walks to shore sits down and we take
back off going
uh when he passes out on the on the on
the shore uh
goes to it and basically they put him in
shock trauma
uh two surgeries later uh gave him blood
for two days
and we had to go film the next gig in uh
jamaica
so we fly out and not a single person on
his whole level of
the hospital it was a john hopkins
hospital it's a real nice place but he
goes
my dad's singing when he got back he
goes man yes i showed up
the people at mcdonald's spoke english
he goes i got approached
by 10 call women that all spoke english
he's like not a single person the most
educated place down there spoke any
english
i woke up two days later had no idea how
i got there
why i was there had surgery got freaking
bags of blood attached
and you [ __ ] left me they said you
were gonna be fine
anyway we have a good good family
relationship there and uh he
he hadn't done anything stupid since so
you're so he did that was his last thing
he didn't remember the actual accident
you're telling me that
he he lost all memory of all of it like
he was
he was pretty much dead like he uh he
bled
bled out so he took him took him three
days to get back to where he was
conscious again
how do you bleed out when it what did he
internal internally
uh yeah artery so basically when you
shatter your pelvis uh the
um the femoral arteries right there
evidently but yeah so he he bled
blood like sam we had actually similar
injuries so he bled two thirds of his
blood volume out that's
the same as i did when i was like 14 was
that when you severed your spine
yeah so he did half of what i did he did
one side where i did
both both sides of the side joint you
passed out too right
yep well i passed out right away he's a
little tougher it took a bit longer to
pass
out yeah dude